Recently, SpaceX announced its plan to provide
better Internet to people around the world
with a constellation of 4,425 broadband satellites
between 2019 and 2024.
They’ll orbit in 83 different planes closer
to Earth than most existing communications
satellites.
And SpaceX isn’t stopping there.
Looking ahead, the company hopes to add another
7,500 satellites in even lower orbits for
faster signals in heavily populated areas.
That all sounds great.
But how can we just put almost 12,000 more
satellites into orbit?
Space seems infinite, but there’s a lot
of stuff already up there.
The key to adding new satellites is that they
don’t all go in the same place…
Some satellites are in a High Earth Orbit,
about 22,000 miles above the planet.
This is a sweet spot for geosynchronous satellites;
they orbit the Earth once per day so seem
to hover above one point on Earth, a great
location for weather monitoring and communications
satellites.
Closer to home are Medium Earth Orbit satellites,
some 12,500 miles above the Earth’s surface.
Orbits here are consistent and dependable
making this an ideal region for GPS satellites.
And lastly we have satellites in Low Earth
Orbit, the area between 100 and 1,200 miles
above the planet.
These satellites are in circular orbits that
vary depending on the mission needs, and this
is also where the International Space Station
and Hubble Space Telescope orbit.
It's the easiest region to get to, so a pretty
popular one.
Currently, there are about 1,200 operational
satellites in orbit.
About half of these satellites are scattered
throughout Medium Earth Orbit and High Earth
Orbit and the remaining half are in Low-Earth
Orbit… the same region SpaceX is eyeing…
and SpaceX wants to add more than ten times
that much!
But it’s not like SpaceX will throw them
up pell mell.
Satellites are launched into orbits deigned
not to interfere with other satellites.
And satellites in the same orbit all have
the same orbital velocity -- meaning they
orbit at the same speed and aren’t likely
to hit each other.
It’s like a team of people driving laps
in go karts.
You can’t just join in and change speeds,
you have to find a gap and match their pace.
But satellites aren't the only thing up there.
There’s a LOT of junk from dead satellites
to spent rocket stages and discarded fairings.
And every launch creates space junk.
We’ve seen over 5,000 launches since the
space age began in 1957, and that’s created
over 20,000 piece of space junk bigger than
a softball!
We can track a lot of that, but there are
little bits and pieces that we can’t keep
tabs on… dust from solid rocket motors,
coolant from old Russian nuclear-powered satellite,
even flecks of paint as small as a grain of
sand.
And those tiny things can pack a punch, that
one fleck of paint can hit a satellite with
as much force as a 550 pound object traveling
at 60 miles per hour!
Not all satellites can avoid this debris,
but some, like the ISS, have to dodge that
junk.
So SpaceX’s proposed new constellation of
satellites will give us better broadband,
but it’s also going to clog up LEO that
much more, and make it that much harder not
only to send satellites into safe orbits,
but it’s going to get that much more hazardous
for manned missions to fly through that growing
debris field to other planets.
Can you imagine being up in space and seeing
random debris float by outside?!
That’d be an experience, and speaking of,
did you know we have a sister channel called
Seeker VR?
It’s everything you love about Seeker, but
in 360 degrees!
SeekerVR will take you on some incredible
journeys that you probably wouldn’t get
to experience otherwise.
Like in a recent episode, we took a ride on
one of the most deadly trains in the world.
Check it out here.
And speaking of space junk, the oldest dead
satellite up there is Vanguard 1, launched
in 1958.
If you’re curious about that era, check
out this video from my own channel, Vintage
Space.
What do you guys think about all this space
junk?
Let us know in the comments, be sure to give this video a like
and subscribe so you never miss an episode of Seeker.